Howard Stern Show you say the audience
were about to do this song yeah some
dude some big dude in the audience
stands up and folded his arms and his
head to the side and looks at looks at
me and I knew was Stephen Stills and
that we had to sing it in front of him I
think that took some balls on his part
did you did you get nervous I mean I
mean you've been performing a long time
since you're a kid but do you get
nervous when the songwriters there - oh
yeah yeah and what is he saying what is
he yell out he didn't he was just he
didn't yell out anything he just stared
at us and terrified us but he did come
backstage after and tell us that we had
done a good job that was a big deal did
he stand up through the whole song um
the entire song and he was the only one
standing up and it was just very should
have thrown him out Randy where was this
that this happened in LA yeah I want to
say it was like at the Orpheum La the
Orpheum yeah how many years ago was that
um this was during the Bear Creek tour
so maybe like five years ago five years
ago yeah take me back to that night
before we get into anything else sure
here you are with the twins you guys
have been performing mm-hmm it's five
years ago we're at some theater mm-hmm
Stephen Stills is watching you in the
audience with his arms crossed and you
break into this song in front of Stephen
Stills yeah go ahead you guys do it now
right now okay stand up and fold your
[Music]
helplessly Oh bringer Harlequin
lovers nearby a waiting you were
gasping a glimpses of gentle true spirit
he rots wishing he could fly high only
to treat at the Sun a goodbye
I
be watching he waits by the window and
wanders and the NZ place inside
heartlessly he'll bring himself to her
bad dreams he worries here a goodbye
Oh reborn' hello
they are one
in person they are too
[Music]
three together they are fun
the Howard Stern Show